saint quentin en yvelines c'est un parc
d'immobilier d'entreprise de 4,6
millions de mètres carrés six grands
pôles économiques et une cinquantaine de
parcs d'activités parmi les nouveautés
le nouveau siège de bmw france à
montigny le bretonneux un site de 15
mille mètres carrés sur cinq étages qui
accueillera quelques 900 collaborateurs
un investissement de 100 millions
d'euros pour le groupe automobile
je vous propose de partir en immersion
sur ce nouveau site
[Musique]
vincent saly mon merci de nous recevoir
dans le nouveau siège de bmw france
bonjour et bienvenue dans ces
magnifiques locaux
[Musique]
alors pourquoi avez vous choisi de
construire ce nouveau siège
alors nous avons choisi de construire
d'investir de déménager de changer de
siège pour deux raisons principales la
première c'est que nous étions dans un
bâtiment qui avait 40 ans on pouvait pas
continuer très clairement il n'était pas
aux dernières normes il était
indispensable d'avoir un bâtiment aux
dernières normes aux normes pardon aux
derniers standards écologiques et la
deuxième raison c'est que nous sommes
trois entités juridiques différentes en
france
bmw group france vous n'allez cité la
filiale commerciale mais aussi la banque
bmw finance est une activité de location
longue durée alphabètes et pour des
raisons de transversalité de synergies
au niveau des équipes il était important
de se retrouver dans le même bâtiment
donc aujourd'hui nous sommes tous
ensemble ici à montigny mais quand même
un symbole un derrière ce ce site
l'emplacement de ce site ça fait depuis
1980 que vous êtes installé à saint
quentin en yvelines
il ya une symbolique derrière ça il faut
rester sur le territoire de 50 ans il
est indispensable d'être sur saint
quentin en yvelines pour pour plusieurs
raisons la première raison c'est que ses
clés c'est stratégique parce que ses
proches de paris mais pas dans paris
c'est ça permet de vraiment d'être à
proximité de tous les partenaires aussi
de haut niveau des activités marketing
et autres c'est très central en france
par rapport à nos partenaires
distributeurs
nous représentons 7000 emplois en france
mais il direct globalement ici et bmw
distribution mais aussi 6000 indirecte
dans les concessions donc ça c'est
indispensable
et puis très clairement
montigny-le-bretonneux saint quentin en
yvelines les les yvelines en général
sont très dynamiques
on est très proche du golfe on est
partenaire de la fédération française de
golf et nous avons le siège de la
fédération qui est juste à côté
donc c'est vraiment un endroit
stratégique où il était indispensable
pour nous d'être présents vous avez eu
900 collaborateurs sur ce siège et
justement on va aller voir comment les
collaborateurs ont été impliqués dans la
construction
2 siège de bmw france
[Musique]
amy omer bonjour bonjour ni par
alors avec vous on va parler de la
conception de l'espace sur ce nouveau
siège
comment at il été pensée sociale des
cultes et pour nous ce n'était pas
uniquement un emménagement au sens un
nouveau site
on a voulu vraiment en profiter pour
repenser tous nos espaces de travail
également tous nos modes de travail
du coup on a proposé à tous les
collaborateurs de bmt group en france de
réfléchir
deux aspects principaux dean par
l'aménagement de nos différents espaces
mais également comment on souhaite
travailler tous ensemble
donc vous pouvez voir ici on est sur un
open space type où les équipes peuvent
s'installer mais on a également d'autres
types d' espace avec des espaces plus
informelle où ils peuvent se rencontrer
donc on a des salles la cafétéria qui
est très sympa on a une terrasse
également où les équipes peuvent
partager un moment de convivialité mais
également travaillé on a des espaces
sportifs des espaces également de
relaxation un cabinet médical
voilà donc les équipes vont réellement
pu design et à leur manière et faire de
cet espace ce qu'ils souhaitaient
le lab justement c'est tout
une équipe de travail a été spécialement
dédié à cet espace là et la volonté
était vraiment d'avoir un endroit où les
équipes puissent se réunir et échanger
entre elles
simplement pour pouvoir brainstormer
réfléchir sur des projets plus ou moins
stratégiques de manière à penser
innovation et à se projeter sur l'avenir
merci les millionnaires merci beaucoup
[Musique]